Hey happy Saturday you guys we're back
Pookie's just sleeping right there in
front of the cam which doing pole key
you know she wants to put her butt up
but yeah yeah it can't be the show
without her butt in the camera we got
some movies in today we got some movies
too every day is like Christmas around
this yeah cuz somebody's sending us
stuff check it out check it out got the
blu-ray of Halloween classic also yet
another classic Craven yeah and it's
like it's funny because we had actually
we were scheduled to do to do a movie
retrospective on this for next week and
we had just been watching it on shutter
and I just like watched half and I was
like really tired and I fell asleep but
it's like this will be much much better
because this will have extras and stuff
like that on it which will be good for
the review so it's either view I I guess
it's from I don't know if it's from its
from Joseph or Mary to be like yeah
there's several people that had said
that expressed interest in sending me
stuff and I'm not sure it's probably Rob
I would think he's the one that usually
serves us movies but we do get ones from
other people too so I'll find out who
sent them and then I will thank you by
name because I'm not really sure yeah um
so yeah we're kind of sleepy today last
night well yeah we stayed up really late
like recording the show and it ended up
I just I was just editing it earlier
today and it ended up being three hours
and 43 I got I got a loaded started
going off about how I wanted to be able
to Cody and Ian yeah I don't think I
made any sense I remember what you did I
think yeah I was like editing it today
and like I had gotta kind of had to
scrub through and like skip through and
stuff but yeah so I'm not taking forever
to do it but it seemed to be a really
entertaining show okay it's like I
really thought it's two different topics
but I was like you know I thought it'd
be an interesting topic but then like
once I got into it and once we kind of
gotten into discussions about it and I
started like looking more into it
it actually ended up being like one of
the most fun shows I think that we've
done in a while I mean most of our shows
are fun but like this one for some
reason this one just seemed like really
interesting and I guess I was just like
in the mood to talk cannibals that
cannibals can even more cannibals yeah
and we didn't even like talk that much
about food I was expecting us to go off
on like all this food stuff like we know
the Jeffrey Dahmer show but that didn't
like about Chuck Norris never so yeah
yeah it was Chuck Norris and Steven
Seagal was talking about yeah it was
bothering me because we were talking
about and I mentioned this on the show
too but it's like you know I've seen for
whatever reason
pretty much every Chuck Norris movie
ever made and because my ex-husband I
used to be like a big fan of his and so
he kind of forced me to sit through all
of them and so aren't you to appreciate
the Norris I guess good Chuck wise yeah
I've seen all of them but it's like I
didn't really I'm not really into like
most of his more action movies like the
Octagon was good but there was one and
it's driving me oh I just remembered and
I couldn't remember on the show I said
the only one that I really liked was he
was in a sort of horror movie like were
it was like a serie he was like after a
serial killer um there was like martial
arts and [ __ ] and obviously because it's
Chuck Norris that we're talking about
but it was more focused on the serial
killer like the thriller type of aspect
and I liked that silent rage that's the
[ __ ] name of it I was trying to like
yeah I was trying to like think of it
last night of the show that movie it was
like right on the tip of my tongue and I
couldn't think of it and then I just
forgot to look it up but yeah I just
remembered it like 20 seconds ago I'm
not a hundred percent sure how he became
an action movie hero this is because of
Bruce Lee yeah had to vent yeah well
because that's how he got his start in
what [ __ ] which one of the Bruce Lee
movies cuz he fought him yeah in one of
the cuz Bruce Lee trained him right like
for a time I really didn't like Bruce
Lee movies well he only made like four
we made like four of them and I
certainly think there was anything
really to him I you know I mean I liked
Enter the Dragon
yeah kinda I can't remember anything
about them yeah they didn't really stay
with Oh kept but see if she can open the
door yeah cuz I think the door of the
office of closure might go over there
and open it she's got her little hand oh
oh she's probably like oh yeah she's
like okay in here all right she's not
funny
she's like like all last night she slept
in between my feet I'm not really sure
why
yeah she I don't know why that is she
just she just likes to sleep bye mommy I
guess I don't know why uh chuck was a
thing I thought all of his movies were
pretty bland they are it really wasn't
much to them I didn't think yeah it's
very strange how he kind of became this
big like cultural phenomenon yeah maybe
that's why because he just seems like
this very and I think I said this on the
show - it's like I just don't think he's
not very charismatic know what I mean no
I like I saw I think I've seen most all
of them in that and I always just felt
kind of like why I mean the the
missing-in-action wants where he was and
the Delta Force Ones I remember that
they were kind of a little more amusing
yeah
but the other ones I just thought they
were just not much to him he doesn't
have like a lot like a real distinctive
personality and it was kind of like he
felt like he felt like it was over yeah
I mean even back in the 80s it felt like
it was over yeah like it was being
replaced with asbestos Stallone and
Arnold Schwarzenegger and you know and
even you know the guy from die hard
Bruce Willis you know it felt like they
were that you know they were the main
players at that time well because they
were more like a character right and I
mean Bruce Willis team and start out as
an action story started as like a comic
act where you never I saw whenever I saw
Chuck Norris movies cuz I rented it yeah
and you know I mean it was like a B
title well this is the only thing it was
all right now you know knows just why
yeah we don't have like a lot of choice
right and you just kind of had to take
yeah [ __ ] Sheldon AV galerie and I
can't really remember anything about
Chuck Norris movies but but you know
other movies I can remember remember
Stallone movies yeah
even his bad ones like I remember Cobra
you know that's bad well yeah but that
was like really cheesy and John yeah
did you see over the top yeah you know
what the course I did don't remember
that was my military school oh that's
right that's right the one with this
[ __ ] did you do what was the one with
the which was funny they used the cadets
from my school the accident my my
headmaster Colonel Shay was in it I
think I had just left I just gone to
Brazil when they when they used it
alright but they didn't use the location
they did or all they use some of the
locations but other locations were not
the school ok because they didn't want
to interfere with the daily school opera
operations - you don't omit well yeah
you can't like disrupt have all these
and I guess they didn't think the campus
looked as good as what they wanted some
of the [ __ ] look like it was [ __ ]
done near Arlington Cemetery or
something big marble [ __ ] yeah that
wasn't you know the front of the school
had some cannons out in front of it
and then just like a white house with
columns but you know just they they
filmed a lot of that at another location
yeah I can't remember if I ever sat
through over the top was bad
yes very well I just I remember seeing
the trailer isn't being like who thought
that was a good idea and that was like
when and whenever the [ __ ] that came out
what we actually saw I liked Roadhouse
the Roadhouse is a de lucky right it's
just it's so bad but it's like so
entertaining I think they were trying to
I don't know I don't know what came out
first maybe a road maybe maybe a road
else I think was 87 maybe yeah II was
over the top I thought over the top was
like an early night I thought it was
1990 to be honest but I could be totally
wrong
well the top is a lot earlier I could be
totally wrong I think it was you know
mid 80s maybe 85 and then it wasn't
there also cliffhanger which I don't
think I ever saw like I never sat
through the whole thing however [ __ ]
case cinema I believe did a
retrospective on it and that was very
funny this is how dumb Hollywood is they
wanted to reboot cliffhanger okay well
they're remaking out they want to remake
cliffhanger but not with Stallone even
though I think that's his property I
think he produced the original one
he might have yeah and it bombed okay
well yes it's a dumb idea [ __ ] dumb
idea they want to reboot that movie and
then gender swap [ __ ] Stallone to a
female well that wouldn't work well the
thing is why don't they just make like a
mountain climbing movie with a woman if
they was insane and just call it
something else
this is that's just how dumb corporate
name is cliffhanger it's not like it's
some like beloved run property from back
in the old days but they could afford it
I guess that's not gonna happen now
because they were talking about that oh
yeah the pandemic but yeah it's a
[ __ ] stupid idea it's what [ __ ]
corporate [ __ ] jackholes the way they
think they're like oh that was the
Stallone movie oh that's got fans yeah
but the same recognize but this this
this not use Stallone all right we'll
gender swap it out to a female because
we don't want Stallone's fans yeah no
like well who are you [ __ ] shooting
for you know and do you think people who
are not fans of Stallone will go see
cliff hanger Christian the law is not in
it because pretty much the only people
that would watch the original it's just
house it was a terrible yeah yeah just
it's just how stupid corporate
executives are they're just [ __ ]
stupid well I just feel like yeah
they're just kind of like their whole
thing is well name recognition they
don't really think they don't seem to
think through like you know the fan base
for the particular film was this film
even popular with the fans would anybody
and the thing about it too is that this
happens a lot with horror remakes and
I'm not not saying that all her remakes
are bad because I've seen some good ones
but um it really does seem like I'm not
really sure who they're trying to target
with audience because I said you know
hardcore fans of the original are not
gonna be role receptive to a remake yes
they're sick of that happening and then
it's like you have to kind of
water it down make it pg-13 and so like
that to get to a wider audience and it's
like those people are probably not going
to give a [ __ ] about it either because
it's like they don't have any nostalgic
attachment to the original so it just
seems like there's two different
audiences and you're just like whipping
it in both cases exactly and that's why
that's what the that's what the
corporation's did with both Star Trek
and Star Wars they're like they didn't
know what made Star Trek or Star Wars
great they didn't they didn't know they
didn't care they just know that it was a
property and it was worth money and they
were like let's make it a you know and
then they're like we don't really want
the original fans we want more than the
original fans because the original fans
is a small group we need to make it take
it to the big group okay so we have to
make it for everybody and when they
water it down like that it's now no
longer what it was you lose the original
fans and then you're not gonna get the
new audience that you wanted because
they they don't want to see [ __ ] Star
Wars or Star Trek you know I mean that's
not their deal it's like you're not
gonna get me to go see silver Cinderella
you can't say like you know what we want
Cinderella but we don't want to
cinderella's fans there's not enough of
them Lissa peel to Tom in particular
this makes Cinderella man and then we'll
put him on on roids mandela mandela and
in watch that will give me a k' yeah and
yeah yeah this is something and we'll
make Cinderella at action fat calm and
Arella
everytime in the [ __ ] university will
see it and [ __ ] everybody will love
it and all the girls will love it
because it's Cinderella [ __ ] stupid
corporate telling you like if they made
Mandela and he had to do all the stuff
wearing a princess dress yeah a tiara
I would totally watch that [ __ ] you
laugh at though it wouldn't well yeah
but it would still be entertaining it
would not be a billion dollar property
well no and that's what they you know
they want of course that oh 1.5 billion
dollars [ __ ] you know and it's gonna
be a
it's gonna have prequels sequels and
[ __ ] three-inch well I feel like
anything everything's gonna be yeah and
they're gonna do that [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] you know a Cinderella reboot
rebooted for men it's not gonna [ __ ]
work yeah I love it there just Corp they
don't have any talent or well the thing
about it is that yes there are movies
that appeal to a broader audience and
will make billions of dollars like the
Marvel movies and [ __ ] like that but
it's like you know not every movie has
to appeal to everybody that's okay you
know what I mean not okay for them
because their core I know and they're
just we're like making as much money as
possible
the corporate suits and they paid a
certain amount of money for a property
and now they have to triple their Malkin
investment well you know that means
numbers yeah right and you can't take a
cult movie then that was a spontaneous
thing that happened in 1977 or or a
thing that failed on television Star
Trek failed on television yeah it didn't
get popular but when it disintegrates Oh
much that you to take that magic okay
and try to make that for everybody it's
kind even when even when the shat was
coming back with Leonard Nimoy to make
movies those movies weren't that big
yeah all right start what is it
Star Trek the motion picture the very
first one bombed basically it didn't
make I don't think it made enough money
on firstly it was kind of critically
panned I like it though I go back one oh
yeah that's you I actually ended up
liking most of them yes our movies
they're prints we've been rewatching
mobster they held up yeah and the day
you know people were kind of very used
to that kind of [ __ ] I remember the
first one I like a you know motion
picture I thought was really good the
first one that blew me away though was
rather calm
whatever Wrath of Khan is like pretty
much everybody thinks that's universally
yeah with the fog to be the best one
Mexican Superman Ricardo Montalban you
know that was the next sign current
five chest yeah people thought that was
a fake chest that was not a fake chest
Ricardo was a [ __ ] man he worked out
he was in his 50s he looked [ __ ] good
man yeah for his age and he was what do
you mean he makes like a really good
villain you know what I mean yeah he
just chemically that character was
really good even yeah when he first
showed up in a TV gravitas
yeah and and what was funny is even
Scotty says you know the you know the
augments you know they were bad they
were tyrants but he was my favorite one
he was kind of cool maybe how he lived
you know they gave him a woman to let
him go you can't be a dictator anymore
yeah he was [ __ ] Ricardo was the shed
man I've seen him you know well yeah I
mean that's the thing too it's like when
we saw the Blum house
Fantasy Island which you know was not
terrible I enjoyed it was fun it was
funny is amazing it was amusing but yeah
but you can't I mean some characters I
mean Ricardo Montalban is mr. Bryant
it's just kind of like I was thinking
about the other day
like when we were talking about Willy
walk on the Chocolate Factory you know I
I know it's not you know the original
movie wasn't real close to the book but
Gene Wilder to me is Willy Wonka nobody
else can play Willy Wonka because that's
just that's that's that character even
though he's nothing like the character
in the book but well some characters are
just so linked to the people that play
them that yeah anybody else that tries
to play them it's just not gonna work
and it's not like necessarily the actors
fault that tried to do it it's just well
Kirk Kirk was was a character basically
you know fine-tuned and created by the
shat yeah you know they had a lot of
input those name was Spock and Leonard
Zane one spot that's why it's hard and I
liked Zachary Quinto who did Spock in
the you know JJ Abrams movies I think he
did a really good job he's a good Spock
but Leonard Nimoy I mean that was his
character I mean he pretty much came up
with that well I was kind of
Ricardo Montalban and [ __ ] Khan yeah
you know he defined that character and
then when the movie came out you know he
[ __ ] had a lot of input on what what
Kahn was gonna do and how he would have
reacted to [ __ ] yeah
and it's just you know that was back in
the day when an actor could have input
yeah yeah I mean I don't think they let
him do that it's Mooji one day well not
on maybe zillion dollar movies but
probably like most independent ones yeah
it depends on the director I would
assume because some directors are more
open to you know feedback from actors
I'm hoping okay and in recent years in
the past [ __ ] 10 years and we
revisited this movie there's really only
one [ __ ] masterpiece in the past 10
years when it kind of comes to action
sci-fi and that was [ __ ] fury road
yeah that movie holds up every just
again a couple nights ago yeah I've seen
it like 12 times all the four elements
of the apocalypse there you're not a
main [ __ ] in terms of male and female
with just you know what Jake's gasoline
and blood and milk and water to [ __ ] you
and you know for elements you know and
the gender with male and female all you
know that theme that ran through it I
liked it yeah I think I think whatever
whoever backed him wanted him to have
kind of like during that time that was
the beginning of kind of like you know
gender representation you know where
they had to bring more of that into the
[ __ ] movies and really you know that
director he already kind of had some of
that but I don't really think of it that
was his thing but I like how he did it
kind of like in an alchemical format
yeah you know I mean there was a lot of
symbolism in the movie to try to balance
you know kind of like male and female
energy that's you pick up on the movie
you know them in the Medicare there's a
lot going on and that's a lot yeah and
there was a lot going on in road warrior
yeah a lot of people don't realize it
you know but there was a lot of
subliminal messaging in the road warrior
especially centered around a Javid
captain yeah yeah what he was wearing
and you know what was on his [ __ ]
gyrocopter and who he was actually the
gyrocopter
the gyro captain was the hero of the
movie not really max max was Calvin
he was an antihero yeah he did help in
the end you know I mean he did he was
honorable he did help those people out
but hey Katie what you doing man she's
moving [ __ ] around she's like she's like
what but the real hero that got deployed
and saved the people with the job was
the gyro cab yeah and you know I mean
there was a lot of stuff and you know
what he's wearing and you know there's
much of messaging in there you didn't
notice that yeah well then well I think
that's why those movies have like you
know that people still talk about them
today's because of like the subtext that
they had yeah that's trying to retain
his [ __ ] a civilized side to himself
you know I mean he's motivated by love
and [ __ ] in women young women all over
his yeah IRA copter you know yeah trying
to be a romantic figure in [ __ ]
alright so you want to wrap up wrap it
up I got [ __ ] I gotta do yeah and like
probably cooky looks like she's about to
like stick her and she's moving the
camera she keeps like moving that she's
like this is not comfortable I'm gonna
lay down on the desk and the cameras
just look at the camera the [ __ ] are you
do when she's like given this space we
refilled her little uh her little water
things this morning I don't know if we
ever said this on the show but we have
the one of those bowls that like you put
you fill up this big water jug and then
you turn it upside down and it like you
know keeps filling up the bowl and she
loves that [ __ ] like whenever it gets
refilled and all the bubbles go up in it
she thinks that there's little she
thinks the bubbles are little creatures
little creatures coming from another
dimension so she's trying to like catch
him so yeah so she like her little arms
like go around she's like yeah and it's
like she always has whenever you fill it
you put it down on the floor
she'll stare at it for a few with her
little head cocked to the side like
watch of the bubble yeah and then all of
a sudden she'll jump in like trying to
get it it's like really funny we try to
get we had video of it somewhere but I
don't know what happened to it
alright so uh hopefully you guys have a
nice rest of your Saturday and we will
talk to you guys again tomorrow
see ya